en corse dix mois après l'assassinât du
préfet erignac les enquêteurs semblent
se tourner vers d'autres pistes que
celles du monde agricole suivie jusqu'à
présent depuis la semaine dernière c'est
en effet chez les enseignants
nationaliste que les dernières
interpellations et mises en examen ont
eu lieu un milieu qui ne reste pas sans
réagir alain chabod christian walter un
convoi de voitures de police sur
l'aéroport en fait le transfert vers
paris en milieu de semaine dernière de
plusieurs militants du milieu enseignant
parmi eux jean castela depuis mise en
examen pour association de malfaiteurs
en marge du dossier erignac
les enquêteurs reprocherait à ce
professeur d'histoire géographie en
poste dans ce lycée de bastia d'être
impliqué dans la préparation et la
revendication de certains attentats
ça relève systématiquement d'alain trick
monsieur castelat est passé à strasbourg
plus tard il ya une attente à strasbourg
donc forcément monsieur castelas y est
pour quelque chose les 6000 ce cas cela
n'a pas pris l'avion le soir parce que
monsieur car cela avant vite se divertir
il ya forcément un relais ça c'est ce
qu'on appelle la construction
d'intrigants histoire ça on appelle ça
le révisionnisme jean castela
aujourd'hui incarcéré étaient également
chargés de cours ici à la faculté de
corte dans une filière tourisme pour la
formation de guides professionnels
il organisait donc régulièrement des
stages sur le continent pour ces
étudiants son interpellation est une
surprise jamais pour pour en enseignant
tueur est engagée jamais aucun discours
politique n'a été intégré dans ses cours
en aucun cas d'autres parmi ces
étudiants ont été inquiétés comme cette
jeune femme encore choqués par ces douze
heures de garde à vue je me suis en
train de dire mademoiselle vous avez la
liberté de pensée ce qui est autorisé
par la loi
je vous laisse méditer cette phrase
c'est tout simplement l'officialisation
du délit d'opinion avec ses 3500
étudiants l'université de corte fait
figure de creuset culturel du
nationalisme n'est jamais jusqu'ici la
division nationale antiterroriste ne s'y
était intéressé dans l' enquête sur le
meurtre du préfet aujourd'hui nous
pouvons être quand même inquiet lorsque
l'on voit l'état
passé de la piste agricole à la piste
enseignante sans aucune sans aucun
élément cela pour nous cela s'apparente
à la chasse aux sorcières alors en signe
de désapprobation étudiants et
enseignants à pélissier à une
manifestation en milieu de semaine
proche